[Musica]
benvenuti sarà ieri e oggi nuovissima
challenge dovremmo mangiare e comprati a
poggiardo base di un solo colore per 24
ma cerchiamo sul pallone deve fare il
nostro colore il mio ovviamente è il
rosa è quello di vitale e qualcuno
mangia compra qualcosa di un colore
diverso perde e chi compra e mangia le
cose più belle dei due vince sarete poi
a decidere chi vince alla fine del video
potrete scrivere ai conventi se ho vinto
io ti brosio vitale team verde chi vince
potrà mangiare tantissimo spero di
ricevere in più siamo in viaggio
quindi oltre alla challenge vedrete
anche un po di blog del viaggio e sarà
come se voi stesse viaggiando assieme a
noi sarà quello che sostiene sarà
bellissimo ed etv comodi privata
relative bokolo gelato e iniziamo subito
questa avventura assieme siamo arriva
del garda guardate che meraviglia
[Musica]
sono già in vantaggio presunto sono dei
ravioli alle verdure bene anche dentro è
dentro ci sono le verdure pernice
l'avvicina la cipolla e la carota
molto buoni
ridurre malattia dura tutto è pronto r
sono questi che sono poco poco gialli ma
è come se fossero verde tutto avrebbe
detto tutto verde penso che ne eravate
accorti
se ne uscì rosa con fragole
nutella e scirocco alle fragole vediamo
come
certe
buono
dopo l'assenza alla saggia
allora questa
questa è una letter la sabbia per fare
le formine però io lo utilizzerei per
tagliare la torta ogni sorta e serbia
[Musica]
buono
aiuto
e poi fortissima abbiamo comprato troppe
cose se si curiosi di vederli mi sono
dimenticato di dirvi una cosa
importantissima ecc
provate a usare un mi piace entro 5
secondi gb e proprio 32 e ora iniziamo
il nostro super mega vol
i commenti potete anche spiegarci qual è
la vostra cosa preferite tra le cose che
abbiamo comprato inizia con evitare
perché non lo spazio a comprarsi tutte
queste cose vitale ha comprato perché io
ho dato il mio meglio sul cibo
io non so se si sentì sono il video ma
vitale ha detto che questa qua serve per
schiacciare la sabbia fare tipo in
classe di di sabbia le sculture no
invece lui ha detto che utilizzerò per
tagliare la torta anche la pizza guarda
funzionamento ravizza però la pizza un
po più piccola statua già ci fosse ma
devo dire che questo verna è identico
praticamente alla sua moglie è stato
bravo ora vi faccio vedere cosa ho
comprato io che ti poi mi scrivete anche
con la cosa che mi è piaciuta di più
sono super curiosa poker e allora
abbiamo una bassa per capelli di mimì
che carino
[Musica]
la vita come starò meglio sicuro sarà un
bellissimo presto che è un vasetto per
poi mettere delle piantine al tiro delle
piantine che mi seguite sinistra abbiamo
sapete che io adoro le piante un sacco
di piante infatti sono mi seguite andate
a seguirmi 9 realizzatori so se volete
seguitemi anche su scritto che poi anni
ma smettila delle calze perrotta e non
mi sembrano tutte rosa cioè ci posso
fare niente non potevo comprare quei
parassiti una rosa già quest'anno delle
capitali da da minnie e topolino
la maggior parte di negozi in cui
abbiamo comprato queste cose sono
primark e tiger da da da da queste sono
bellissime no no delle pantofole bianchi
no però rosa o bianche sono delle
pantofole unicorno non so se riuscito a
vedere che carine sono anche
sbrilluccicose
il corso vecchio anche pelosa che cari
ma anche tutta questa parte bianca non
potevano essere tutto questo non vale
queste comunque saranno per l'inverno
perché adesso permettere queste poi
abbiamo un'altra fascia ma non per
capelli questa è per gli occhi sapete
che ne ho tantissimi praticamente io le
collezioni e questa è del principessa
aurora videochiamata solo non lo conosco
come non la conosci la bella
addormentata
si chiamava mauro non ho dormito o
dentro il gel fresco come mi sta
benissimo ciao io voglio pensare delle
lenzuola rosa ovviamente ho raggiunto io
non lo voglio rosa che vide costretta
vernero dall'orologio superstar da
reperirsi una copertina rosa per
l'inverno con i pon pon
e questa paura che merlino la
distruggerà perché penserà che un
giochino per lui ogni volta che vedere
fallire va e le distrugge quindi
dovremmo stare molto molto attenti
questo è un campanello per la bici
quindi data cara la bce de rosa e offesi
da tiger onerosa volevo fare un forno da
guerra che viola questo posto al popolo
è scuro che stanno delle racchette con
questo qua che non mi ricordo come si
chiama volano forse collina con la view
ma questa sarà per giocare in giardino
anche se anche in questo meno rinnovo
sicuramente dove lo mangerà quindi
dovremo stare molto attenti a non
comprendere americani quest è un
come si dice in italiano e quello che si
attacca alle valigie alla valigia e
dietro mesi il suo nome cognome numero
di telefono nel caso che la valigia si
perde di quelle di minniti che righina
che brutta questo non è rosea che
bruciare pro del nero prova del nero con
una maglietta rosa e per rosa resta devo
dire che rosea come vista lunga mi
sembra troppo lunga però ti sta bene le
orecchie di mimì sono stupende perché
sono rosa ma sono anche glitterate
guardate brillano san rocco a melo
provare di tempo mi stanno attestano
bella che abbiamo da lavorare
easy mostrate le corna che cristo
pricipessa la principessa poi ho preso
questo è un orologio grande per la casa
marco questo perché non vedo
penso che questo rosa senso per rosa è
un orologio peloso e tipo vellutato in
un peloso per tutto a posto e ai numeri
d'ora siccome la gente dorati l'odore
questo mio preferito l'orologio veloce
il mio preferito
ultima accolto bra che vada
i viola erano da usa russia
questa è una piastra in minialtura per
ibm capelli medio più corti hanno
effetti potrebbe portare i suoi capelli
lasciate un mi piace se volete che
provola pa3 miniatura sui capelli di
vitale se questo video ha raggiunto i 30
mila mi piace estero in appello evitare
quello mi piastra tutto e così via
non ci sto a questo non è rosea e questo
è viola e rosa
verrete chicche lo dimostrano sa tutto
il resto non solo piccolissima noti in
italia da te la mia mano guarda capitale
vince perché la vita non è rosea
le cose che compratori da ma sono tutte
anche tu non sei verde in faccia vuoi e
fuori basta considerare che cosa certo
niente
a queste cose ci sono ancora
questo non è rosea aspetta dallo devo
spiegare o dell'uso delle gare fra i
parchi non c'è in italia sono in tre
città lontanissime dal sud e quindi non
potevo perdere questa occasione
beh comprare tutte le cose che mi piace
ormai ho perso la challenge però la cosa
la prima qualcuno sabato ciao ciao che
quindi ammetto che ho perso dal
challenge però punto non potevo
resistere a prendere queste cose
bellissime
perché non so quando tornerò qua al nord
e che la mitra gialla giu invito ad
hazard
mario mi faccia vedere le altre cose
dette e lo stesso la maschera per gli
occhi di steve mccurry
proviamo la vediamo un po al di basile
che ti sta molto bene la mascherina
distizione arrivate non lo so ti
assomiglia
poi ho preso queste calze di stranger
times sapete che sono una grande fan che
vedere un e così le casse una così una
con la scritta e poi la più bella
secondo me è questa perché al posto
delle lucine sapete se avete visto
stringer things che ci sono le lucine
colorate hanno messo dei glitter
colorati velino noi abbiamo questa e per
vitale l'aie tela su per me
sta zitto
proviamo e queste vogliono le riprese tu
queste beh io mantiene così gigantesco
voluta dall'upi di prato qualcosa che
non è verde venne imposto anche tu
decideremo poi chi pizza in base alle
cose che abbiamo comprato perché anche
vitale ho preso delle calze gigantesche
incalza vale quanto sono gravi invece di
dare per la simpatia non riuscendo ad
offrire la cosa più bella basca del bar
bene poi ho preso questo per l'italia
per una maglietta gialla righe che cai
faccia entrano due di vitale dove gli
sta secondi poi chi sei mai giocato alla
vaniglia 2a maglietta giallo blu
mi piaceva tantissimo questo colore fluo
questo è giallo canarino di gravità
questo è giallo fluo del giallo canarino
poi questa maglia
vitale mente di prenderla perché è
incredibile ma in questa maglietta se
sono vorrei farvi notare che merita e
verde
tutte le mattine risultato si sono tutte
le cose che volgiamo e credibile
guardate vi facciamo vedere in pratica
ci sono tutte le cose che mangiamo c'è
l'avocado il tofu qua e il latte di
mandorla qua e poi l che se nella sede e
adesso che ho detto e gli archi abbinati
come facevano a sapere che mangiamo
queste prove e quindi un'altra maglia
per vitale grazie
la banda ha voluto analizzare questa è
una di quelle buste riutilizzabili in
pratica una volta aperta è così e così
mi piaceva un sacco
questa è in rosa dopo di che è un po
rosa e grigia neri e rosa anzi come
farfalle per me una maglia a righe
gialle diamo noi poi sempre per me una
maglia ma a righe nere
certo non è rosea l'ultima cosa questa
maglia con le righe allora scriveteci
nei commenti qual è l'oggetto che mi è
piaciuto di più potete mettere il time
stamp quindi il minuto è fatto così
gli altri possono cliccare vedere
esattamente loggetta lasciate un bel mi
piace fateci sapere chi ha vinto e ora
vi lasciamo al 34 caselline su cui
giocare per noi dei nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao
[Musica]